"Spring forward, fall back," as the saying goes.
Many countries change their clocks twice a year to observe Daylight Saving Time.
The practice was first introduced in Europe during the first World War...
...but was only fully adopted towards the end of the 20th century.
The idea was to take advantage of the longer summer days by gaining an extra hour of daylight...
...and shortening the days in winter
It wasn't a new concept.
Back in 1784, American inventor and politician Benjamin Franklin...
...suggested that starting the day earlier in the summer...
...would save a considerable number of candles.
Those in favor of the practice saying today's energy-consuming society...
...the environmental benefits linked to changing the clocks are considerable.
While only small amounts of electricity are saved per household, added up they can be significant.
Lobby groups however argue these savings are negligible, particularly in the winter...
...when the afternoon advantage is offset by the need for more light in the darker mornings.
Farmers cite other disadvantages, for example the unsettling effect on cows...
...as milking cycles are disrupted.
The elderly, the sick and children are also thought to have difficulties adapting.